so there I was woke up with a heavy case
of amnesia in the middle of nowhere the
only clue to my past is Harry's name and
address inside this hat so I made my way
to the apartment and that's when I found
you and your stapler gotta loosen a shoe
so you're a talky Pikachu with no
memories who's addicted to caffeine I
could stop whenever I want these are
just choices another round extra shot
I don't know maybe hair got in too deep
and mixed up the wrong crowd that kind
of thing you could talk to humans I can
talk to Pokemon and if you want to find
your pops we're gonna need you to know I
don't need a Pokemon what about a
world-class detective Harry is still
alive case closed
but still open until I solve it all
right
here it is Harry faked his own death
or somebody else faked carries death
[Music]
or Harry
fake somebody else's dead that last one
doesn't work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now obviously I've dealt with this putz
before so I'll just do it again hey bud
what are you doing I can't do when
people are watching
[Music]
that's a twist that's very twisty
no no he's barely moving don't tell him
that
oh he's on a bike quick get in front of
him stop oh no he's going down hard Tim
should have worn a helmet
you